on oublie peut-être mais le château de
versailles est empreint de mythologie
l'exposition versailles et l'antique
nous rappelle que le domaine jadis
baigner dans l'antiquité collectionne
les références aux dieux et déesses
louis xiv en rentrant en installant la
cour et les gouvernements à versailles
en soit 182 lui à coeur d'acheminer
quantité d'oeuvres antiques à versailles
même au xviie siècle antiquités est
perçue comme un enjeu politique
des artistes du roi redouble d'efforts
pour que leurs créations rivalisent avec
les beauté antique et les collections
sont riches mais le prestige du
souverain est reconnu si à l'époque
versailles est considérée comme la
nouvelle rome ce titre est aujourd'hui
moins présent dans les esprits
le drame de versailles c'est qu'à la
révolution en fait tout le patrimoine
mobilier avec soi été vendus soit est
parti à paris ou fourni les collections
du musée du louvre le musée du louvre et
le château de versailles ont donc
travaillé conjointement pour présenter
aux visiteurs 200 oeuvres entre
sculptures peintures tapisseries et
objets d'art savait qu'à cette époque là
l'étape était très sourcilleux sur leur
patrimoine y est très difficile
d'exporter des antiquités de rome et le
14 normand a réussi à retenir trois
durant son règne et des pièces majeures
qui sont présentes dans cette exposition
il s'agit de trois statues germanicus
cincy natus et le centaure albanie si
louis xiv a pu rassembler
des antiques venus du monde entier comme
le moyen-orient avec l'apollon de smyrne
il s'est aussi vu offrir des sculptures
à l'image de la vénus d'armes dans
l'exposition au premier étage on peut
voir de nombreux tableaux réalisés sur
des thèmes antiques à la demande
nosu collectionnés par lui ainsi que des
éléments de décor du mobilier des
boiseries des vases exposition compris
dans le billet d'entrée du château est
accessible jusqu'au 17 mars 2013